نديم هل وضع اسرائيل الاقتصادي سيساهم في
قرار استمرار الحرب من عدمها قصه اقتصاديه
قصيره كما هو الحال في اتفاق الهدنه الذي
ادى به الضغط الشعبي على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لخوض هذه الهدنه سيؤدي مقدار
الالم الاقتصادي في اتخاذ قرارات ربما
تؤثر على قرارات الحرب على غزه دعونا
نضعها في الارقام الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
الان يعني ربما تكلف بحسب تقديرات شركات
الخاصه الاسرائيليه كلفته هذه الحرب للعام
الحالي الجاري والمقبل بحدود 48 مليار
دولار طبعا هذا اقل من النسبه التي تحدث
عنها محافظ البنك المركزي امير يارون بان
تصل هذه الكلفه الى 54 مليار دولار اي ما
يعادل 10% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي هذه
قيمه كبيره ايضا البطاله الموضوع المهم
البطاله المنخفض التي كانت تساهم في النمو
الاقتصادي الاسرائيلي الان ارتفعت من
3.8% في سبتمبر الى تقريبا 10% في اكتوبر
وهذا اعلى بثلاثه اضعاف هذه كلفه اقتصاديه
مرتفعه ايضا الحكومه الان اصبحت تنافس
القطاع الخاص في اسرائيل على السيوله حيث
اصبحت تستدين تحديدا من السوق الداخليه من
خلال اصدار سندات وهي بالتالي اصبحت تحد
من النمو الاقتصادي ايضا من القطاعات التي
تاثرت بكل هذه العوامل قطاع العقار وهو
كما نعرف عالميا هذا من اكثر القطاعات
المحركه للاقتصادات الان كثير من
الاسرائيليين تقدموا بطلبات لتاجيل اقساط
قروضهم العقاريه هذه ربما مقدمه لما نراه
بتراجع الطلب على العقارات تحديدا في تل
ابيب وهذه كلها مؤشرات تشير الى ان القادم
سيكون اسوا من حيث النظره الاقتصاديه
المستقبليه ايضا قطاع السياحه عاده في شهر
اكتوبر من العام الماضي زار اسرائيل بحدود
380 ال سائح شهر اكتوبر بعد السابع من
اكتوبر فقط الذين زاروا اسرائيل يصل الى
89000 سائح وهؤلاء حجزوا قبل السابع من
اكتوبر لذلك نعرف ان الشهور القادمه ستكون
مخيبه للتوقعات وربما تصل الى النقطه
الصفريه فيما يتعلق بالسياحه الى اسرائيل
كل هذه العوامل ستساهم وهذا ال
في القطاعات الاقتصاديه ربما يلقى صدى لدى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويؤثر على قرارها هل
نستمر ام توقف
الحرب